[Müzik]
dalgalar içinde gizemli
kuş Ömür renklerine Aldandım
Gözlerin içinde bir yer var sadece
kırılmaz orada
[Müzik]
Gözlerin içinde bir yer var sadece
kırılmaz orada
[Müzik]
hatalar başına dolaşır Ağlama
duymadın ses
uzaklaşır yorulmuyor
mu buraya kadar denilen her şey
biter mi Bitmez mi
Pınarın altından Düşler
girer mi girmez
Gözlerin içinde bir yer
var sadece kırılmaz orada
[Müzik]
Gözlerin içinde bir yer var sadece
kırılmaz orada
[Müzik]
hatalar başına dolaşır Ağlama
duymadan ses uzaklaşır olmaz yorma
buraya kadar denilen her şeyi biter mi
Bitmez mi
kapıların ardından düşer girer mi girmez
[Müzik]
mi
Gözlerin içinde bir yer
sadece kırılmaz orada
[Müzik]
ışığı
Gözlerin içinde bir yer var sadece
kırılmaz Orada ışık
[Müzik]
üşü
[Alkış]
Çok teşekkürler Öncelikle her hepinize
Merhabalar kısaca kendimi tanıtayım Ben
Ceren Toksöz müzisyenim aynı zamanda
müzik öğretmeniyim küçüklüğümden beri
Şarkı söylerim şarkı yazarım sonralarda
şarkı öğretmeye müzik öğretmeye başladım
Kısacası hayatımda buradaki Hayatımda
çok büyük bir alana sahip ilk
denediğiniz şarkı Işıklar adında kendi
bir parçamdı bundan
6-7 yıl önce gerçeklerin peşine düştüğüm
zaman yazdığım bir şarkıydı o zamanki
sorgulamalarım
Bugün de size yine kendi şarkılarından
oluşan aynı zamanda Dünyanın çeşitli
yerlerinden müzikler yapmayı çok
seviyorum Şu anda bu aralar
ekibimle beraber dünya müzikleri
yapıyoruz böyle size hem kendi
şarkılarından oluşan hem de farklı
kültürlerden küçük bir performans
sergileyeceğim Hepinize iyi dinletiler
ikinci şarkım Aslında
çoğunuzun belki bildiği bir masaldan
esinlenme küçüklüğümden beri bildiğim ve
beni çok etkileyen bir masal bu Ama niye
ise çok da masal gibi gelmeyen bir masal
çok
gerçek gelen bir masal benim için
Bilmem belki bilirsiniz Kibritçi Kız
diye Bundan Birkaç yıl önce
karlı bir günde evde otururken evimin
karşısında büyük bir tarla var ve orası
böyle çok karla kaplıydı o zaman oraya
baktığımda Bu havada çocuklar ayakları
çıplak
yok mu Kibritçi Kız gibi ya da aramızda
dolaşmıyorlar mı bu kadar bir masal mı
gerçekten Kibritçi Kız diye kendi
kendime sorup o anda böyle hemen oturup
yazdığım bir şarkıydı bu şimdi sırada
sizler için Kibritçi Kız gelecek
[Müzik]
donmuş küçük bir kızmış
orta yerinde
kibritleri var da yakacak her
sana çok yürümüş çok yürümüş
üşümüş çok da üşümüş Ayaz kalbine vur
Muş yok
hiç
kimse
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
yok Hiç kimse yok
hiç kimse
[Müzik]
nereye dal
Ak nereyi bakar saçlarının saçını hangi
rüzgar taraf
dayak gibi
[Müzik]
çıkıp sana olmak için bazı mı gerçeksin
Güneş
kimine doğar kimine
bataryanın tabanına hangi toprak tutar
Hayal ki
[Müzik]
bir çıksan olmak için
bazıları gerçekçi
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
gözüm nereyi bana ner
elere saçlarını saçını hangi rüzgar
taraf
dayak gibi çıkıp
masal olmak için fazla mı gerçeksin
Güneş
[Müzik]
gibi İnan
kimine bakar ayağına sabahına hangi
toprak tutar gel ki
masal olmak için
bazıları gerçekçi
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
teşekkürler
masal saatinden sonra Şimdi de bir ninni
okuyalım
bu ninni seferatların ladino dilinde bir
bir şarkı geliyor esmer kızın ninnisi
diye
[Müzik]
kendisi esmer kızın ninnisi kara kızın
ninnisi şeklinde geçiyor şarkının içinde
beyaz olduğundan Ama yazın kuraklığıyla
güneşiyle karardığından
bahseden bir kızın ninesi gelecek şimdi
[Müzik]
o re mi Kamil
e'de Sude
[Müzik]
delikanlıyım
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
ve geldik son parçaya bu şarkımda yine
Balkan tarafından gelecek Balkanlardan
gelecek
Ederlezi diye
ederiz Hıdırellez anlamına geliyor ve
dünyanın birçok yerinde kutlanan
baharın gelişinin sevincini ve
umutlarıyla beraber
kutlanan oyunların oynandığı dileklerin
dilendiği bir Bayram Bu Bayram o yüzden
şimdi sırada ederiz gelecek
[Müzik]
sana
bak Kıyamet
[Müzik]
çok
Mutlu
[Müzik]
romanlar
hadi
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Esra arama
[Müzik]
[Alkış]